quand on risque une peine aussi lourde
pourquoi on est tranquillement dehors
comme ça alors que lorenzo qui n'a rien
demandé
depuis 10 mois est à l'hôpital et vit un
calvaire quoi
bonjour je suis la maman de lorenzo qui
vivaient ici avant d'être à l'hôpital
depuis 10 mois maintenant
voilà la chambre de lorenzo est pas
rentré donc depuis le 22 août au soir au
moment même par la suite quand il
sortira de l'hôpital là le passage n'est
plus accessible il va falloir faire des
travaux pour qu'ils puissent revenir
c'est très lourd quoi il faut vraiment
que tout soit adapté déjà bien à sa
hauteur les passages en fauteuil ne sont
pas du tout les mêmes il faut qu'ils
puissent avoir une salle de bain aussi
adapté on ne sait pas si ici ça sera
possible d'adapter pour lui mais quoi
qu'il en soit on fera tout ce qu'il faut
pour qu'il puisse avoir une vie des plus
heureuses
était aux alentours de 4 heures du matin
quand une voiture est arrivée avec deux
personnes à l'intérieur et c'est comme
ça que les choses ont dégénéré en a un
des deux qui a un petit peu provoquer le
groupe et a commencé à monter le ton
avec un ami de lorenzo qui était sur
place trois voitures supplémentaires
sont arrivés aux ados a été on lui a
foncé directement dessus sans qu'ils
aient le temps de de faire quoi que ce
soit et même de comprendre ce qui lui
arrivait il a été plaqué donc il s'est
retrouvé sur le ventre et un autre lui a
sauté dessus sur le dos il a été opéré
d'urgence dans la matinée on lui a
retiré les cervicales
on a fait une greffe d'os il a des
plaques et des vis à la place des
cervicales il est resté seize jours dans
le coma
et là ça a été très compliqué parce que
on savait pas s'il allait s'en sortir à
19 ans et c'est quoi le l'avenir
[Musique]
il est paralysé à partir de la poitrine
ne peut pas dire qu'il va rester comme
ça toute sa vie parce que en tant que
maire pour moi c'est pas possible de
dire ça parce que bien sûr il faut
toujours garder espoir et voir plus loin
et dans tout ce qui est trop bas mais
duléry il peut arriver des miracles donc
je vais pas vous dire lorenzo restera
assis toute sa vie c'est pas possible
mais bon il ya quand même une réalité ou
enzo est un jeune qui veut montrer
toujours une une image positive de temps
en temps il met des nouvelles sur sur
les réseaux sociaux il mettra toujours
quelque chose de positif vous le verrez
jamais se plaindre il aurait peut-être
pas cette force il serait peut-être plus
là
[Musique]
chez ma fille en a croisé un dans un
centre de boutique quand ils se promener
tranquillement avec ses parents en plus
et ma fille est tombée nez à nez sur lui
quoi jeu qui a 14 ans et quand même
purement scandaleux il n'y a pas que ça
ils avaient eux-mêmes avaient été vus au
moins d'octobre en terrasse d'un café
tranquillement avec entrain de boire un
coup et ça fait des mois quand même
quand on risque une peine aussi lourde
pourquoi on est tranquillement dehors
comme ça alors que lorenzo qui n'a rien
demandé
depuis 10 mois est à l'hôpital il vit un
calvaire quoi
[Musique]
oh
pour le moment c'est très long c'est
très long on sait que la justice
française est long mais nous le point
pour lequel on appuyé et pour lequel on
se bat c'est pour quelle raison on les
laisse comme ça tranquille si les peines
étaient appliquées plus sérieusement et
que là la justice était moins laxiste
je pense que même nous on n'en serait
pas là des bagarres et des violences il
ya toujours eu malheureusement mais
voilà ça pouvait s'arrêter un coup de
poing la de nos jours on entend des
trucs mais des coups de couteau sans
arrêt donc nous là dans notre cas y'a
pas d'armes mais c'est quand même d'une
extrême violence
ça fait peur pour l'avenir ça c'est sûr
il faut vraiment que les gens jeunes ou
moins jeunes prennent conscience que
qu'il faut arrêter quoi c'est quoi le le
plaisir de détruire des familles des
vies
[Musique]
grâce à donc aux réseaux sociaux et des
gens influents comme rémi gaillard sont
là pour nous aider ça fait dix mois
qu'on travaille plus moi j'étais prof de
fitness
avant ça et forcément je peux pas c'est
pas possible on a deux filles qui ont 12
et 14 ans est très difficile pour elle
aussi parce que leur quotidien du jour
au lendemain c'est transformées en
hôpitaux et justice dire qu'on ne parle
que de ça elles ont vu leurs frères deux
fois en dix mois et notre vie du jour au
lendemain c'est complètement arrêté
notre force c'est lorenzo sa force à lui
fait la nôtre
[Musique]